[Music]
[Applause]
you are actually thinking about are
using
how many of you actually on AWS or a
good intersection
and introduce myself um my name is
Jeremy Carroll so I'm an Operations
engineer
[Music]
I think Soutine everyone for letting me
just here to talk a little bit about
HBase and you see - those are unaware of
interest operates entirely on madness on
web services so when I started but if
you were here in a quarter ago they
challenged us the engineer or
announcement to not only run HBase to
support some of the products I think
about developing by doing on AWS when I
went out to the talk to other people
about their experiences many people
haven't even gone when I actually
talking would be like
Hotel feels like I tried it once wasn't
a good story you know there's old part
of our challenge is trying to figure out
how to make it work to make it scale how
to make a performance so I just want to
kind of preface this talk that I want to
kind of keep this informal so anybody
who has the question and it's burning
just don't wait till the end
what kind of just have that because as
we like to figure that we got this
pretty good operation one not all of it
so this is kind of what we've
experienced one of our practices so I
just want to give an overview of this
one what I want to do is break this up
in a couple of parts the things that I
wish I would have known before going on
Amazon Web Services and starting to
install so the first thing was kind of
the point is grab these recent two
pounds and what that means when I taught
the individual wanting to run HBase on
when the first things they ask me is
with the architecture what is a book
like where need when you're region
servers which is instance side all the
separate questions that kind of come up
it happens to the colocation space but
in Amazon it gets a little bit second
once you actually deploy that stuff to
the cloud how do you validate what you
have rooms that's part of the fun about
delivering new products and experience
the hatred isn't your first breath
probably doesn't work and then you have
a bigger than opportunity to actually go
that's right and there's which actually
have something in production how do you
continue to support me you know
challenges to kind of really go to
pinterest.com
do you see something we call your home
of all the things that you follow that
innocent people
that is extra cartilages so all of the
intimate wait log them in query HBase
feed a list of all their time and water
that you use of all the pens and things
I followed and rinsed on their tongue
the second thing is that make sure that
analytics products for business so
basically if you want to get information
valuable insights about how your
individual pins are doing we have a
business analytics product which kind of
show great here and then actually Batman
is part of a huge basis one we store all
the statistics and information in
addition to that we have something we
like to call on rich bands which are
basically pins that are have a lot more
metadata about them a lot more
actionable an example that would be a
recipe they actually go on Pinterest you
see recipe and you click on it don't
have a lot more information about
directory it's kind of hard to see if
that experience work but you get like
ingredients and things like that all
that metadata is actually stored in
agents and then we actually crawl the
information of the internet that can be
enriched and then add that to that
object and then when we render that we
can actually render the additional
energy feeds on that so we have many
different types of bridge pennants from
movies to recipe serves to a bunch
different things so these are just some
of the trucks that we actually support
an interstate very user facing what a
lot of behind the scenes non visible
things I think right now I think we have
six or seven different production of
basic clusters for profit engine soul in
each basis well regarded as a
first-class product and support somebody
wants to launch a new feature
we have no qualms about competing their
support so usually when I talk to people
they're like let's to plug what's the
person they's in they say all right and
when I want Sonny to to where the
instance types in its insides I mean how
do I actually tune this to run and I
kind of go through a couple of them so a
little bit about Pinterest we've run
kind of this just art we run the solid
state clusters which usually use out the
high one for Excel which are solid days
back I will teach something newer seen
three instances which are also also
solid state back because the costs per
eye up on those really really high up
instances makes a lot of times if we
actually have a lot of storage but not
as many ops that kind of cost about them
so the other way and we usually gem one
guy next largest or vice versa something
with a lot more storage space but not as
many higher so it kind of becomes a
balancing act and which one we use based
on equates really really have your
reader mode versus not so much but it's
on a Sunday like if we have one is
eighty million rows and not too much you
know reload or right load that maybe
will look for a Saturday poster personal
selling their classroom in addition to
that there is some hub concepts with
Amazon Web Services you have to be aware
of when you're in your own colocation
facility on a data center you get total
power to find everything you can apply
your top ranks which is again by your
racks and roads with your hardware are
you're going to make it exactly what we
want to you don't necessarily have that
choice without in time especially when
it comes down to a high availability
architecture you can actually craft a
rack locality script for your own data
center think that's really robust and
put you know the first block placement
at one row in the next one in a
different room in that data center maybe
even in the third in a totally different
data center you have that ability in
Amazon they only give you the
constructive and available
zone take guarantee that your placement
is actually busy exactly that means that
if I'm in a region such as us East one
which is where the interests of located
and I have different availability I was
available to me if I want to guarantee
that those blocks are not placed
anywhere near each other for power loss
or vice versa I have to say they don't
really like to see inside that black box
essays in the same room same zone
if that's the magic the clock a limited
capacity we have no intersection other
than the concept in addition to that
there are certain things that come with
the psalmist a firm's called placement
groups obviously that allows you to
10-gigabit full by section family and
you get that with some of the more
expensive stylistic clusters but that
actually is a constructs that kind of
guarantees details because when you talk
to Amazon and they say you put long
distances into a place where they're
going to be closed you don't know how
power supplies exactly the other cost
also because of that if you're
interrupting the high availability back
over that strategy with that you're kind
of you know make some inference that
have you know place with no crashes and
there's a problem physically with a
datacenter they may know crash but you
don't know that so usually when I talk
people they kind of have their ideas
they're in your back locality with the
availability so as to how that looks
like that you're the first design I kind
of get into so this is kind of more of
the money common design hydros I see the
individual is user base we have three
availability zone which is you at these
like one a one
and then what you will want really
really legendary liability so to do
something like you Jam or bookkeeper the
general manager / I am knowing but two
of those in different availability zones
then for the zookeeper ensemble for
HBase to run it on one you know at least
one in each availability on for three
total and then they you start balancing
the reasons it is putting them online
each individual availability zone and
you know that's a pretty rock-solid
designer you know it's you know I can
use one availability don't hopefully you
test it who came to exercise on that day
to prove your hypothesis hypothesis is
correct it looks pretty good when we
were starting to Pinterest we were
looking at some of this stuff this
design because just because one you know
cluster one set up is really high
available we want them logically
separate aircraft so that all for some
other benefits like let's say for
example we did take a total cluster how
they do them we do something like da
something major we always wanted to run
to so that we can have the ability to
shut down one cluster and shunt traffic
to the other cluster so with that
designs we actually went to these you
know hopefully to logically separate but
them the goal was that the way that our
application works is that front-end team
most of our HBase clusters is a pool of
Thresh servers that's how we communicate
with HBase is always through the
straight edge we have five nine clients
we have non Jade Java client all want to
communicate with beige base so all of
our HBase clusters are fronted by a pool
of three servers depending how much
capacity on this PBS
where's your summers so we actually have
a system in zoo keeper it allows us to
switch live on the fly where our traffic
over so if we need to take one cluster
down we can actually modify the
configuration and everybody just moved
to the second cluster and then we can
take that cluster down to me so one of
the nice things but regardless of what
age of architecture we want what we
wanted to do but we looked at this in
brain in production we thought that we
can get simple so one thing that we
wanted to do is to make this
operationally simple so one of the
tenets that we always try to do inside
reliability is to make something really
really great but then try to simplify
this as much as possible make visibility
possible so we started taking a look at
a different type of design and the
design that we started looking at was
let's not try to get this thing super
brutalize let's go ahead and put
everything one availability zone let's
call it like an HJ cell and it's a bit
doubtful since we don't really have
multiple availability zones it doesn't
really make sense for us to invest in a
highly build with name to it or vice
versa at this exact time and if it's
just we're gonna run three kinds of
keepers whatever you want and then as
many breeki servers as required there to
support that selling as we kind of saved
the benefits of this is that it's
incredibly simple but it's not very
reliable may notice a single 24 and it
will back also an Amazon has a great to
come we kind of joke internally that
Amazon gives us a cast monkey for free
it's called Amazon Web Services so
sometimes they'll send us a little
notices saying that your name DoDEA is
going to be decommissioned in 14 days or
through these scary news and they go oh
god no now you gotta go ahead and switch
this little cluster or vice versa but
the benefits that we gain from that is
that we gain a lot of simplicity so when
we launch into the system to choose what
it's on they are I'm going to exactly
which one they are if we have a
placement purposes or solid state
clusters that we just watch that place
okay operationally repairing a zookeeper
you know for this is really simple
there's no foreign Germany to W Asian
community vice versa now I'm not saying
that we're not considering looking at
some of those things but at this exact
point in time it was easier for us to
get operationally simple but as HDFS 2.2
veteran comes out we may take advantage
of looking at those days sometimes the
name note just needs to mean isn't
easier to not shuffle a whole cluster of
questions yeah either zookeeper in this
diagram is actually the zookeeper for
the HBase HBase ESS out so that's the
one that matters communicate to the
review servers communicate to the money
that is region this time in the vice
versa
the one that we have internally we
actually have different no Verta
paxos installs for different products
okay I mean at this point in time I just
focus on HBase we have a lot of other
uses of interest like so they counts up
to this doctors trying to focus on these
so continuing on the reason why we kind
of like this architecture in general
suppose we went to as I said we always
want to run two of something so we kind
of get a pseudo high availability in
note in the fact that we actually run
two clusters it's not as good as the
other diagram by a longshot but from our
automation perspective we can automate
this there these a lot of the code that
we did with auto scaling or Python or
vice versa looks pretty easy with this
and it's a lot more mentally easy to
integrate so for example if a region
server failed with a model that showed
before we had three availability zones
good to make sure your fantastic stays
balanced and at one known at what
availability time is then you're going
to unbalance your stuff at that one
in three two recent distribution and
then for availability if the cluster
gets wounded for example and you do a
game to exercise man you better have the
capacity to be also certain limit so you
lose 33% your capacity off the time and
then you're going to be integrated so if
you got your service agency a lot better
about the passing point an example that
one lecture tried the first way we
forgot to tune the DFS bandwidth per
second and we said it as high as it
possibly could go which leads on a great
attack this way senator been networking
this one thing we're actually testing
but when we funded is that we make shake
it lost availability zone or there are
quite a few regions servers and one zone
that the balancer ban which took over
the clusters idle and then in the link
to check wait pasteurizing
so pretty much when the cluster is going
to tell me so it's with this pen at the
time he had won Custer's will get it out
so if it's greater than anyway we just
switch over the other cluster then we
find the time to go ahead and pair that
so hopefully in the how to make fashion
and then get back that's the design
we're kind of doing right now but where
I was wanting to revisit
[Music]
it's good question their question is
that what type of load are wearing to
design before recite through foot in
place or something
we actually have decision matrix at
Pinterest that was trying to make sure
we're choosing the right versus some
storage technology but like questions
the right problem domain we try to limit
each basic use case the things that have
really really high light and we have a
lot of other storage technologies and
the great success charting my sequel
charted by this different types of
storage technologies I've been dressing
each basic cells really good we're using
the hollow cemetry to it
so for example the one diagram I showed
you with the HOME key since the classic
example we have an excuse right
application if one person thinks
something and they say they have a
thousand dollars
that's not great one thousand points so
it kind of notice what the thousand
times right application event for that
one user we did ninety percent more
bytes that are exactly discipline we get
about so with that system I mean
sometimes we've seen two million
operations per second on that cluster
and most of it so right but it all
depends on the application
but there's the kind of things we try to
do if it's interview locally is he
serving with a smaller dataset from an
event for that
[Music]
I'll be magnetic percent less than ten I
have to echo I mean I think it terrible
not better this time whites I think
[Music]
going into the next nice kind of general
how we architect on just the other
things that we actually writing space
ninety four ninety four point seven is
will run right now we experiment
experimented unafraid 94 15 for some
certain blood fixes one thing that we do
is which qualify our releases because
since we actually stress test our
servers much much heavier than the
average user in HBase upgrades are not
in curricula for us there's a little
tiny corner cases that may have a unit
test or simple integration test they
want you to warm up online so we make
sure that the upgrade cost we take time
to upgrade and test Buster prejudiced
abandoned rather 280 now so we're a
little far behind I was there we don't
have plans right now to go to 96 there's
the newest version something we don't
want to get sued for the community
[Music]
fantastic question the question was that
our our SEP we're trying to do active
active or active master or a Passover
vice versa the current setup that we do
is actually active passive
reason why is because it's a little
easier for us to support that whenever
we're not as concerned about wasting we
would actually find a little bit simpler
that I should support active passive but
that is a muscle that is only good when
is exercise so we switch actually
clusters quite often just do that for
example if I want to do optimization
a major compaction event that's going to
you know in fact latency and it's really
long and it didn't have the capacity on
that cluster to actually do it while
online serving will just switch the
cluster over performance maintenance
operations switching back so unlike the
traditional hot coals
I kind of call it a hot war because make
should do that quick if we didn't do
that often have a little more risk
averse that C is actually don't work in
these regions as we do that you know
[Music]
prick the question is what type of
cluster management tools that we use is
it in how it serves somebody else it's a
very great question what would actually
looked at deploying on HP's we wanted to
stand on so the reason being has got a
lot of redistributions up to do your
favorite one i think they're all
beautiful ones have their favorite ones
or whatever I do as well but we want to
actually refund which based on ourselves
and inactive ourselves we deployed
results mainly because we keep you know
tighter to what's available on the
community then that company like work
works or culture nobility
[Music]
other the reason they flex with the
reason why we use our own internal tools
because we actually manage to HBase like
our other purses and storage technology
that interest we have our own very
communicative ways internally how we
manage what we use therefore a lot of
the things that actually accompany with
all present cluster management solution
doesn't fit within our sre mentality so
from us it's a lot better for us to
manage and maintain that customer just
because to go to whatever cluster
management Lu provided by a third party
we want to add additional capacity so
hooking into our internal infrastructure
we may or may not have access their
sorceries so this thing is that what you
actually get something out there you
know make sure each place must be going
we have a lot of new product development
as they kind of said before and
Pinterest a lot of people are using
space for new products we're developing
new thing all the time we're launching
new clusters support new services so
high fatality
you know things like schema design load
testing so we should go production in
the future it's a non-event the last
thing that we actually want if there
should turn out a new feature to the
public it's actually powered by one of
our storage technologies like HP this
rust I do not know how it's gonna so
basically trying to talk about the
methodology about how you actually
develop your solution hunting space and
how we validated it correctly
unemployment I talked about this a
little bit H based on last year is we
did ordered a lot of individual internal
tools and scripts to help us kind of
validate us scheme so one thing that
they're more common issues that we
usually see is kind of taking a step
back that we see people design things
for each base is Regency for
distribution of data where you know they
had a wrong idea what that was going to
be there's like one region server join
the majority and that can manifest up in
a couple ways a manifest itself is a hot
region where the requests like the data
is even distributed request drawn and
one conserving the word could be the
actual data is lopsided
where you actually have one reader
server that has maybe 70 gigabytes where
the store files and everything
ten megatons no those are the things
that we kind of see in production and
the reason why that's important is that
I can't add capacity to an HBase cluster
if I can't add capacity and happiness
so I can't explode my work up by like I
do if I can't split the books
so one thing we want to make sure is
that if we do that how do we actually
are my little Sherwood
perhaps we open sourced some tools that
we want to do work us we developed a lot
of our visualization experiences people
they would entertain snapshots of age of
a table with HBase clusters and see you
know kind of in general actually I've
worked in my pocketbook
so this was one bottom one rating
distribution of store files so in sort
of all science so basically showed kinda
like a bimodal distribution of data so
there were a ton of it was right here in
the middle and kind of like a histogram
play out these things in the end
terrible time they never getting your
request is pretty much so here we have
actually went to production with that
it'd be pretty interesting scale another
things that we wanted to do at the end
just look at in general a cluster so how
do we know how many things we put on one
cluster
how much this is just all the story this
is just some visualization techniques
that we used to kind of say that just
laid up and I think looking at data
distribution that's one of the easiest
ways to kind of think about the problem
mainly for the fact that the majority of
the times I was spending actually
supporting production workflow cases it
usually comes down to some unforeseen
event an example would be somebody can
have a really nice fair distribution of
data with md5 you know type of topology
but they didn't you know plan for humans
and that's what happens when the edges
are in production
take for example if there's a really
popular user and you don't have any
memcache or anything else like that in
front of the system and that person is
really really popular again the best day
is there sufficient world that rate
servers you know and then there have you
guys are techniques to try to catch that
try to get those off
it's kind of about another thing I don't
want to talk about in general and
passion so when I was talking to some of
the other colleagues that run these base
clusters there's kind of you know like
almost like a pro but you can only take
as much data as you can actually impact
so when you're twinning these clusters
for workloads you have to make sure that
you can actually serve low latency
online traffic and then still keep up
with your big white boat to make sure
the contacts let's keep it off I'll blow
an example it means is that if you don't
have enough idle capacity for custom
let's say you undersized them then don't
wait yeah
mister seeing latency get really really
bad because there's a lot of stores we
look at your right load use even hey
there's a lot of Reds come them and it's
taken a long time to compact you're like
well wives take a long time to compact
look at the disputed issue I hope to
pass a no system you would you don't
have enough Ohio is to actually conduct
that answer at the same time so you kind
of get in this catch 22 where you get
into pylon rights and then your Reiser
hit install and then your customers are
happy to just the SLA on the clock and
then nobody's happening because the
system just basically ate itself and I
think that is more common for most
people when you start to do day-to-day
they start to see that as they do
something like they do to populate this
which basically everyone else to do
great sledgehammer
it's going to come in as fast as
possible yeah so one thing that we only
try to do it to make sure that we're to
any compassion we can keep up with a
little bit you see online sees if I keep
in a store positive and make sure their
connection strategy can handle
complaints
now that sounds all fine and dandy now
how you do it is it's based on I've
never seen a generic thing other digit
did generics out there the base suitable
so really good if you don't have a
problem I'm gonna say you probably don't
have to mess with that stuff going into
the compaction code and looking how to
join it that's pretty pretty scary other
but I was saying that some of the tools
that we actually used to determine we
need to do that there's a company called
centric committing animal which is
really great looks at log file but you
can't action time
techniques we do some stuff with develop
and walk palaces which you probably
can't read really far away and then some
in visualization techniques to know how
fast our mem story is filling one what
should happen which is that the
storehouse go up and at home only amount
of time that do an anecdote that I'll
actually give about that is like when
you have a hybrid and as I said before
we try to put things with lots and lots
of rice inside of each base you have to
tune what's bigger there's something
there that's great
I need to tune your H logs as well so
for example this D fall out of the boxes
you get I think 32 times 64 megabytes
worth of H log 2 gigabytes or 13 times
so if you sit your meta store size we
can actually take five gigabytes worth
of stuff people you have to watch and
you don't turn that variable you'll get
an appetitive
so that you give to tune all these
things kind of in flight to each other
an example that we exercise pinterest
with somebody to do spot people
clustered in tune that variable and
they're telling us why this is my all my
stuff to stop for a while and then I've
seen the logs too many H logs before
seen flaws and they flush all the
reasons all of the exact same time
and three large clusters they flushed
400 regions at the exact same time
pretty that ton of store files all those
have to be compacted didn't have enough
I just kind of went along and all the
sudden boom links you got terrible the
fingers just recovered a lot later so my
thing is that some of the techniques
that we do is we always make sure that
we're giving visualization techniques
and cluster management tools kind of a
gentleman's question some people can
kind of figure out ex post facto
what happened but usually if we try to
do these other things ahead so one of
the techniques that we do is before we
launch a new product or service we have
an ability to do phantom recent patent
rights which is a fantastic big
capability if your software application
stack doesn't on support them I said
that's probably what your best price
quality of your workspace
an example of that would be what you
need to redo your schema designer
having a tool like a Duke to redo your
input splits maybe do a total order
partition or offline then multiple of
those sage solitons you can keep playing
experimenting with it it's kind of
reminds me a little bit of leucine if
anybody's ever seen usually everyone
does their schema you're not going to
get it right the first these are having
it regenerated in addition to that when
it says when we want to project a
feature we don't want it to be a
surprise when actually so a lot of our
stuff our our website asynchronous we
don't try to do everything synchronous
online users do classes so because of
that we have a queuing system behind the
scene what actually is the ability for
us to do duplicate up both those
requests so we can actually say I'm
going to put 30% code for this new
product the future on that system so we
could say great so all 30% of these
actions will get duplicated and be
replayed again system which has been
fantastic for us to know what evidence
to know what our testing looks like and
it actually looked like real world
production once we actually go into
production the same system will be doing
the exact same thing top it off which is
really nice for us there's not something
cute way it doesn't look anything like
production
that's a good question the question was
that mosquito changed how do you read on
eBay and that's good is that I would
have to ask ourselves that from time to
time it depends some of our clusters
actually one thing we like about these
things is that Mary's really really loud
so a lot of our men do for closing they
actually create artifacts will create
each box and then we'll dose across the
wire in Baltimore so we have a cluster
on one of their products that didn't
mention that front was one that says
things that you may have also want so
somebody in something will actually show
them other types of pendants that they
made it like based on machine learning
sort of technique and that's served by
each base but that is only art that's
not artifact generated it when the every
once in a while so it can be Volvo
so in that case super simple just go
back to spend over other types of data
that it an example be that each system
that stuff is little bit more complex
because that is real time and vice versa
said now hey I don't think there's a
general answer for that that a lot of
people we have one system internally
that allows us to do a group that
actually helps us a lot so if we
interchange with schema we can go grab
this up one of our backup plus if you
want to redo that table and go to a
period or we can do other types of
events and tips where we just created a
new table one then we just promote the
code actually there's a lot of different
ways we didn't really think it's
architecture in general its witnessed
our thinking about this agent design
your application and if it's the first
kind of boring out that game engage base
I would say Evan that do not absolute
source of treasure here will probably
ensure success because if it goes down
okay so the question was the dobre
capability now this is I think something
specific to us we had we don't know how
to use this one we had this is some
basic rescue for a long period of time
we had a burst of high res which we
contributed matches back up sticking the
handle almost all these interests a
square website so as a man they went to
a redis you know clustered register and
then those things that have retries
packed and then it fails we try to
replay what we actually want to have two
clusters will not have h based
replication that can actually kind of do
it to paste and get your keys right at
home we kind of just are perfect about
one tool it's that kind of a valuable
for us as for the other binary space
clusters and going to production which
has been open to it so the one issue
that we had from operations perspective
and I guess what my operations had
engineering give you visibility into
each base is incredibly challenging any
tool that actually make it easier are
recycling the water comes to support
instruction one issue that we had
initially is that there's a ton of data
inside the page
regions but the ability for our monetary
system to handle it it's hit or miss
based on the type of property you have a
little bit of an energy up we were
actually using graph lines at the time
to do all the rendering of this data if
you're not familiar to graphite it's a
time series data base written called
carbon and every metric point you get
makes a pre-allocated
time series database evidence that means
for every unique data point creates a
bond and that file would be 0 no vice
versa
based on your you know retention period
so for region server statistics I'm
Puerto Rican statistics some of our
tables had 1,800 regions to vice versa
that's 1,800 data point five days now
what we split that data then we'll never
be written to again when we set the
story on this this gala this is
someone's really live accounts this
data's really high cardinality really a
lot of uniqueness and that's just endure
stuff like that didn't like having
mentioned victims for one day and then
that existed so scale this is something
a little bit jealous one thing that's
nice about open tsdp is that you get I
think like one or two lights for beta in
the winters and it's a ephemeral nature
because it wakes doors it so if you
store that a real server for a little
bit of time it only takes as much places
it actually it wasn't like so stores
joining us and scaling the system was
incredibly easy
that was right we wrote in the open
source some code or HBase we're gonna
promote open T is to be their demon
called T collector which will collect
statistics on the interval and send that
over to you
so we were one in Python that was I
capture a myriad
statistics really really high so every
ten seconds since every 60 seconds or
everyone and the next thing about it is
that it has a lot of information so for
example allows us to read request write
request this a number of store files
compacted on a regional basis on the per
table basis and then the provision
services for customers so there's a lot
of a multi-dimensional aggregation
capabilities which really really nice
precise investment so an example was
that don't read this is the contract
I'll put the sides of that word to do
this but basically we have one graph on
the left which shows the distribution of
one table so it was the read request
rate on a per table basis so this one
HBase cluster ate like three or four
tables their load on three professor aid
and then we said okay well just one coke
system right here there's one cable
weathers their region so we want to see
quail happiness we want to know we just
what has been the most dominant region
WY right there
and then lo behold we've had read a
write request rate per region looks
great it's all very important this was
an md5 sum and then if we want even
going further on appropriate audiences
three per table base per cluster per
table and a map of region there so she
keep slicing and dicing which is even
one which that was a capability that we
use all the time when it comes down so
we actually render Omaha graphs and
charts from this data so when we
actually show us some of those things we
should just go
time service battery always go to school
at hot to go for it not the ones that
one major complaint this you lied to get
out of the box it's not very sexy so the
people all appears out there
I personally believe that it is the
insight I don't care what it looks like
it can be a nice bitmap so next time
when customers go into production
so let's actually develop the clustering
is already out there I think some of our
oldest clusters then in production
injure someone here know which is I've
been really missing this operability I
think perhaps we talk about hours of
uninterrupted operability image
basically necessary perspective but what
do we accept to do it actually support
something once it's launched so great
you got your product out there at one
grade you did dark reads and writes the
training but how do you actually
maintain when we have a day one when it
looks like a 360 plumbing entirely
requires care and feeding capacity
planning that's where some papers say
I'm done
there's a little bit talking about how
we do alerting
monitoring health detection elements so
this was a new Y that we developed
internally based on PTSD video because
they're complaints but least the one
thing about this we'll need about
concern is it is powered by d3 a lot
more interactive dynamic stuff we
actually hover over and determine what
system was hot then one actually they
fell congested II was if you have a
let's say a thousand regions for a
thousand lines well there's no way
you're gonna build a free thought like
these with something like this potential
so one thing that we kind of do general
gage of overall health humanism
we have an overall customer dashboard
anyway going to it has the status of all
of our clusters so usually when I say
that we measure that help the pace pace
you're trying to make sure we keep the
metrics really valuable top level
measures we want to know what your a
solid a like what your maybe see that
they're gonna tolerate your cluster has
to have 99.9 percent less than 10
milliseconds 50 milliseconds latency and
it has to have this many errors per
second or less or through or vice versa
we try them and do the business metrics
up front so those are what really
there's a million members on the HDFS
there's a million metrics and a trace
looking at all those in the dashboard HR
haidle the dashboards probably I can
give you like a business value you try
to keep it a really really high level
how is this system performing and a lot
of the things that
in HBase right now with our version in
94 there's not a lot of metrics that
actually time you attend an EFT from
something coming the RPC digging service
to coming back now if you had to enter
response time advances so a lot of the
measurement that we do isn't that fast
but we do it from our stretch flavor and
that gives us a little bit more picture
now extra sponges the numbers because of
maybe it's this rich server that you can
see vice versa but at least that will
for that perspective tell it's likely
that this one overview is a little bit
trickier vice versa where you can also
get into the ones they give you is the
disk latency thank you like FSP reads
for rain debris latency other
participant sequential like you see
inside of HBase but that's just how much
this time it was but if it serve at the
chemist or or there's some other issues
in there a PCP you that won't manifest
themselves there's not really great
scoring brandon response
[Music]
yes
the question is if culture is scalable
escalate oh I don't scale I would come
to see their auto scale thing isn't
really for performance though because
for example if we exercise
lazy that's good question
that's a good question there's good
question the question was probably
latency announced them so when you add
capacity to an H base class you're not
going exactly get any books right we're
actually even if there's a colocation
facility when you add a difference like
a brand new data so HDFS it has no
blocks so if you did everything senti
across the network reading so if you
were suffering from i/o capacity you'd
be something you know like yet
additional capacity X you see a drain on
that as new data comes through and gets
written to that region server and it
creates store files you can pass it will
addiction it over time depending on your
right grade or fill grade and get back
to that cluster but if you're already in
trouble
any additional node is not going to
immediately be pronounced so I think
that we are the scaling for us to
maintain the steady state hopefully we
actually look at our metrics and
forecastle of it so we don't get that
situation we're making sure to add
capacity minute under duress rate
[Music]
yeah I mean question is do we only scale
I would do a scale down and actually the
answer is we never scaled scaling down
HDFS isn't currently tricky from the
block location and black locality also
from the availability you know how do we
decommissioning takes a long time so
normally I don't think we've ever
[Music]
we love
okay
[Music]
okay make sense the pressure is more of
a philosophical vertical skin immersive
or thomaswguy replacement more how
appliances where did we have more than
actually made scale and that's a great
question one thing that we have been
doing is Amazon actually reduces
different instance types all the time it
recently read at least the c3 series
which is actually a solid state which
180 gigabytes worth of solid state on a
very cheap note with a lot of CPU which
makes her kind of great for actual
events ESD plus was fun in that exact
consistent so if there's a new SKU kind
of vertical scale of how dangerous a and
she's more probable we can play around
with that by either creating a new
cluster and that's what we did in the
case of open DSD BBS and total weight
rate crept in a new cluster
happy the data off of that under the new
one and then backfill the data and
switch notes that's kind of how we did a
vertical replacement in a sci-fi side
the next thing about having the cloud or
Amazon Web Services is that we don't
need to ask our finance department for
capex to go spend another million
dollars to get another side-by-side
cluster just like an ugly that's one
thing is it's nice about the elasticity
of their products have been temporarily
I can spawn a totally new cluster get as
many nodes actually need to facilitate
that transfer and then get rid of them
[Music]
other questions
other questions run use case matrix and
Pinter specifically HBase is a low
latency of online scalable pepsinogen
there's a lot of other people that use
that for and that's at the MapReduce
jobs or vice versa we do that in some
cases but at this time it's almost like
on my squad appendage
[Music]
these
it's good question the question was roan
and our key value storage system for
size I don't kind of tell me some things
maybe if generic had a key value 0 like
gives on me over that might rebuild like
some other times it's actually more
structured data an example of the
complete system grew and one of the
columns they talk about back to that
name is very primary key value can be
driving you to other entities you can so
very very high the cell we try to keep
its long that's like we have some some
things actually happen yeah that's
actually the largest I think that we've
actually find the most immoral on
balance so I'm gonna just run a little
bit overview of the dashboard but in
general the kind of things that we
measure I've been said like the
five-dollar metrics the overall they can
see the health of the system on errors
per second bandwidth all those nice
things they have so what kind of call
those baselines
those are tables things we don't want to
cluster at Pinterest that we don't have
a second measure
we don't have an SLA next year cluster
then how are we going to measure make
sure
we need to find one it's less those
guidelines we're looking at error so
your airway detect outliers
so the next thing about some of the
appliance visualization techniques that
you can use the old-fashioned line
there's one cluster reading request lots
of region servers a kind of get a
general idea you can kind of start seen
there's some things that are little bit
higher other so you know maybe you want
investigate that there's a little
distribution but you know what you can
look at that to you in the face if your
SLA is being met and you have no problem
most unnecessary pants on fire another
thing that we actually have it is a user
CPU do we detect outliers and this is
great because there's a lot of
developers that's interests of use
different types of bomb ways to query
the data which may or may not be
something we generally recognize there's
a lot of people learning an example an
anecdotal example is we actually saw a
test cluster that had a one reason
server that was going crazy with cpiotto
we're just wondering what that was we
profiling we found out the person we're
using it and it just atrocious
red-tagged scale you know with a lot of
data really really deep scanner vice
versa it certainly makes it so this is
type of things that we kind of predicate
if I look at the distribution of user
CPU in this case the name you know on
the cluster really low another thing we
do is kinda like a distribution of
scatter plot the data to see my outlier
bands see what the latest
so let's try talking a look at about
visualization techniques so one some of
the tools that we actually use for
operations perspective keep in my
operations have worked really really
well but they fall down when you have a
lot of fun lot of service my pleasure I
didn't have to have a lot of servers you
draw a lot of lines it's kind of hard
just like it so I kind of just put it a
little example out there that having
statistical data analysis frameworks
like on you know I love this because you
can play with the data and just do
different these are the techniques with
a veneer plates a brand new way that you
like for example if I'm going to draw
keep a car and I want to get an answer
it's going to take me a little bit of
time to investigate the framework I'm a
really pretty JavaScript
you want a jQuery magic or vice versa
where they just want an answer I don't
just go into our slice and dice this DVD
so I think it's more valuable if we're
gonna do this all the time that you
invest in the economy web tool but it
was doable for example this one was one
cluster the way I saw it is kind of you
see the day-night pediment distribution
request you know we're a social media
company I think most other type of
companies have that same type of pattern
where we see that natural art but then
we kind of see that you know here's
kinda hard to see like with that look
like actually they're kind of like a
bimodal distribution of and it's kind of
hard to see because there's so many in
life we do the exact same data down here
I don't know
contrast connection shows position but
we kind of see something you know things
show up so for example this is our
lighter darker bainite better here what
we see like there's really weird lighter
bands of surfers in between the lines of
server
I kind of index I think that's where
they use them but you kind of see
there's something interesting things
going and we actually when we actually
looked at this cluster make sure I found
out that there were some betas skewing
this one these server just have more
things to serve and this is a pretty
evenly distributed cluster so this they
had more data to serve it was pretty
bare they were hot and sometimes the day
because humans okay I just want to show
what if some of the things we've kind of
seen instruction everybody likes a good
for story I don't like that kind of
going to get disaster you know what
story today's verse that though totally
don't have to but I might show one issue
that we kind of didn't how we Triana and
kind of Holly support missile production
so he saw it said that high level
metrics the overview the SLA started
going to crap on this cluster so the
latency was normally very very good
normally less than like what I said five
milliseconds although some really weird
work shoots up to second 20 millisecond
RPC cue you know of requesters sky
wraparound the comics cluster the amount
of time we spend in the Q versus
processing those are really weird so we
start being alerted
how this clustering test just because it
wasn't performing and then we go to the
other type of things one when we look at
cluster help we found that the second
one of those reason servers had a really
hot CPU so on the right hand side
100 and then that robot lineman CPU and
the no wonder why this is somewhat
perfunctory well then we proc supporting
that with the overall latency of that to
some the green lines everyone headed
into the server and we started probe on
the job people on the fly so we use them
the ones using this and it's hot threads
there's many ways you can actually get a
straight dump - let's see where's your
time spent hopefully without hooking up
into a janitor front of times our
profile so I click on done in this one
there is a certain type of classic he
died American values this specific one
had a really nasty corner case where a
spammer wears on my site spammer in this
thing loaded up this region on key
values and made the really music deep in
its store and when the scanner bit that
having to skip over on itself evaluated
so then the next event goes up as I can
see so
solutions for that works a bomb with
your stuff don't let some of these game
everything vice versa and then go ahead
and so in general when I my general
methodology so we start off with a high
level and we always end up with you know
we never end up have something that's
going to tell this
there's when I talk really quick about
alerting at Pinterest right now driving
although 13 for our age race hustlers
that problem to sensor is a monitoring
part that was developed a bit
it handles auto scaling in the
feminization health you can use whatever
you know the next thing that we do is we
put our rental counter stuff so that
when things go wrong
additionally Bedford had a high level
you metrics reducer five dad you know X
and then the more type of actionable
stuff that we know exactly how the
events or vice versa I'm not going to
cover but also how do you do backup so
this is one thing that I would love to
communities have done we utilize
snapshots quite then basically we're
trying to gives that we go ahead and
snap out the tables without - time check
utility then we export there was table
in exports actually tossed up with our
own Java code so we can pop it up for
different cluster the thing is that I
said we always have two clusters so
we're just a backup cluster to take our
backups on exactly we don't impact let
you see a low latency survey because we
take all the package line that's where
I'm a parliament on the Amazon we
experimented with copy directly to a
Serena's didn't work out to them s3 has
a lot of little individual former cases
that fail jobs it's sometimes it's not
just performing it takes a really really
long time also from our perspective a
mean time to recovery we did not want to
rely on s3
ability to serve our data as part of our
strategy to get clusters from scrap down
so it opens the kidnappers way to start
running or running to give us questions
so we started running HDFS hi available
you Amazon they're using as a staging
area for backups we take snapshots we've
happened over the age of a stationary oh
and we need to recover those backups
were able to use a stationary to see the
peanut oxidizers for a long time
strategy considering I can only have so
much space for local backups we will
then take and then go in as three to see
P those up from that backup cluster to
s3
now something we're still experimenting
with magnetic products and this quarter
an actual experiment to make that easier
because it's actually relatively complex
in a ball one thing that we actually and
we ended up a lot of work is so there's
a lot of little tiny bugs that happen
with snapshots never resolved it makes
your 94 11 covered fantastic ability
because we don't to disable the table
keep it offline for long periods of time
to make sure it's consistent a trailer
just that it's a little bit involved a
lot of people appreciate also the
recoverability story so once you
actually get your data recover from
snapshot we kind of treat those are full
backup so in traditional backup isms you
have your pull backups their incremental
and you use other type of treatments
that's my sequel you write ahead logging
you play that there's not a lot of tools
like that for page great specifically
right now when we get full backups so
how do we recover stuff in between those
four Packers can we how do we do we get
each logs or walls you know and there's
a summer to play them no other tools out
there no so right now we're kind of
filling in to run internal tools as a
way to recover that data between full
backups but for making perspective
[Music]
actually we can do any so for example in
the event that we actually had a crunch
let's say we had a name known start off
by the exact lesson went down a total
day we would have to respond on a New
Age days cluster and then populate those
backup table so they went into dis CP
and that data back and then importing
the snapshot into recovery and then we
have to get that data back out they
prepare this change set we have the time
to type out the backup we open system to
that period of time we're talking
recovery now you know because if you
realized the amount of time it takes to
get that cluster back up to full
strength is Ritz so if you want that
[Music]
the questions during the business day
work you cannot become I would say we
have time today that are more busier
than others based on the day night
activities of our users but you can call
that Q of a technical ism
[Music]
my question was more when understand the
cost reduction it's not a golfer's we
want to maintain low latency I am
certain and we've granted yet Bokke I
want my persistent I don't want to scale
down my persistent stories to save a
buck one of the online young one
[Music]
I that was a honey for credit sighs your
cluster was the question we did that
through phantom raised our rates at the
Old Testament but pretty much that's an
equation I might talk
Thanks also as a come time to every
other company in the Bay Area we are
hiring viciously
[Music]
[Applause]